[Musique]
quand j'étais enfant j'ai toujours voulu
devenir un pirate
mais il a fallu de nombreuses années
avant que l' aventure ne commence pour
moi avant que je porte ce chapeau pour
faire simple et pour commencer
disons que je suis un touche à tout un
bricoleur comme beaucoup d'entre vous
dans cette pièce j'ai souvent bricoler
les choses qui me venait souvent sans
intérêt
en suivant le fil décousu de mes idées
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour quelque chose
marche quelque chose marche vraiment et
ça a tellement bien marché qu'à un gros
poisson qui passait par là a décidé de
ma vallée un requin m'a mangé façon
sashimis un grand groupe comme il en
existe ici et ailleurs avec son lot de
gens gentils à l'intérieur prêt à tout
pour satisfaire les objectifs de
l'entreprise quitte à y laisser quelques
plumes et la plume
c'était moi et on m'a laissé tomber
comme une plume comme une plume alors on
m'a c'était comme dans un film en fait
hein je suis passé sur la planche
on m'a demandé de sauter par dessus bord
en échange d'une poignée de billets
qu'on m'a donné comme si elles sortaient
d'une partie de monopoly
sauf que de mon côté de la partie
c'était une catastrophe
le sentiment amer coeur plus rien
n'avait de sens le l'idée que tous
méritaient d'être vu comme un jeu on
commence à tu commences employer des
mots grossiers tedx te demande de
changer tes mots est ta femme te quitte
parce qu'elle a peur pour la suite
j'ai longtemps cherché ce que je pouvais
faire 200 c et j'ai fini par trouver
monter un fab lab alors un fab lab c'est
un espace dans lequel différentes
personnes peuvent expérimenter fabriquer
ensemble mais un fab lab dans un bus aux
un genre de vaisseau pirate nouvelle
génération avec à son bord toute la
technologie nécessaire pour que chacun
et chacune puisse donner libre cours à
ses idées
d'abord une imprimante 3d capable de
réaliser n'importe quel objet en
plastique capable de réaliser n'importe
quel objet en plastique
dès lors qu'on l'avait dessiné au
préalable sur ordinateur à tribord une
découpeuse laser capable de suivre
n'importe quelle ligne dessinée
informatiquement et en figure de proue
un centre d'usinage cnc une
machine-outil commandé par ordinateur
nous sommes donc partis sillonner la
guadeloupe avec quelques sympathisants
de la première heure rapidement devenu
fablab heures à la recherche de gens
comme nous des passionnés des inventifs
qui ne recule devant regarde devant
l'expérimentation le code de la
piraterie est très simple tu veux venir
tu viens tu veux bosser du boss tu ne
veut pas bosser tu ne bosses pas tu ne
dois rien à personne et inversement
proportionnel
la seule chose qui compte c'est
l'intérêt l'intérêt le challenge
intellectuel car c'est le seul vent qui
souffle dans nos voiles avec les années
nos idées ont pris corps sont devenus de
plus en plus grande et on a commencé à
matérialiser notre terrain de jeu avec
des lego de cape town chacun des
containers maritimes habitués comme nous
à tenir contre vents et marées avec
lesquels nous fabriquons nos locaux
d'aujourd'hui et celle donc la nouvelle
la nouvelle aventure du bus que vous
voyez ici j'aimerais vous dire que ce
qui se passe ici derrière moi c'est un
cours d'électronique passionnant
passionné est en réalité le contexte est
favorable vous voyez peut-être au tour
tous les tous les outils mais en réalité
ce qui se passait c'était le résumé de
la série de 6,4 jones venir aux fab lab
donc et créer des choses comme ça au
sein de notre forteresse pour fabriquer
à l'abri du regard extérieur avec un
seul ou à plusieurs
oui c'est vrai que effectivement tout
seul un technicien peut faire beaucoup
de choses surtout depuis qu'internet à
plusieurs au fab lab on réalise beaucoup
moins de choses en fait
non beaucoup plus de choses en fait
en fait on sait pas vraiment en fait
voilà ça dépend non ce dont on est sûr
par contre c'est qu'au contact des
autres et en équipe on va innover
beaucoup plus innover on n'aime pas trop
ça parce que c'est un mot qui est un
petit peu tirés à la mode en ce moment
mais disons qu'on va beaucoup
expérimenté à plusieurs nos techniciens
on va les pousser on va aller titiller
jusqu à les sortir de leur zone de
confort ce dont on est sûr c'est que
jamais on va juste effleuré les
problèmes on va aller au coeur des
problèmes ça fait partie un petit peu de
l'adn du lab et c'est vrai qu'on a un
adage olap qui dit que pour comprendre
un objet il faut le démonter et bien
souvent puisque c'est difficile à
démonter il faut le casser
c'est un adage qui est souvent appliqué
chez nous et le capitaine notamment ben
jours a découvert le point de fusion son
téléphone portable avec la découpe laser
ti ludo lui c'est un spécialiste en fait
il s'est découvert un super pouvoir
il est capable avec ses petits doigts de
planter n'importe quel système
informatique
en quelques minutes c'est vraiment un
don extraordinaire
moi personnellement j'ai aussi un don
c'est je suis spécialiste en soudure à
l'arc à base d'oeuf au micro ondes
évidemment
tout ça tout à fait volontaire ça fait
partie du jeu le le truc en fait c'est
qu'on casse beaucoup mais c'est vrai que
ont construit aussi qu'on fabrique
beaucoup de choses à partir d'objets du
quotidien
quand je dis objets du quotidien c'est
plutôt des objets du quotidien qui sont
mis au rebut parce que c'est vrai qu'au
niveau budget il faut qu'on se
débrouille avec ce qu'on a est ce qu'on
adore aux fab lab c'est lorsqu'on prend
un objet du quotidien qui est devenu un
déchet et ce déchet on va le transformer
en outils et cet outil on va l'utiliser
pour travailler sur de la matière
première qui elle aussi parfois de big n
va aussi venir aussi des déchets
toujours pareil ça fait partie un petit
peu de l'adn du lab alors un exemple
type de ce type de projet je dirais de
déchets ses parts dans ce petit cube de
plexiglas de 3 cm 2 qui contient un
micro ordinateur qui vient non pas du
tout en fait c'est pas du tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus simple que ça ça c'est un
objet qui nous permet de transformer les
bouteilles plastique les bouteilles
plastiques pour ceux qui n'étaient pas
là au cours des trente dernières années
ça a été inventé en dans les années 70
et c'était un moyen de contenir du
liquide dans un
récipient pratiquement incassable ce qui
était super à l'époque et maintenant
c'est vrai que ça pose beaucoup de
problèmes environnementaux puisque
évidemment on connaît tous le problème
est donc nous on est décidé d'utiliser
cette capacité de résistance de ce
plastique pour en faire quelque chose et
on va essayer d'en faire de la corde
donc ce petit objet a été dessiné par
des fables haber élevé en pleine nature
on va dire si et et donc ils les
premières versions ont été imprimés sur
nos imprimantes 3d nouvelles
technologies et on a décidé au bout d'un
moment puisque la matière première était
un petit peu compliqué à obtenir de se
lancer dans un nouveau design et de le
découper dans de l'écran vidéo télé
vidéo informatique avec la découpe laser
en petits morceaux de 3 mm d'épaisseur
on assemble les petits morceaux ensemble
autour d'une lame de cutter et on en
fait un objet qui va nous permettre
d'effectuer une opération hautement
technologique dont on espère très
bientôt pouvoir inscrire le nom dans le
dictionnaire de la langue française et
ça s'appelle le soda que taj qui s'y
colle aux pieds ce qui s'appelle un soda
cut
alors plutôt qu'un long discours je vais
peut-être faire une démonstration ça va
être assez impressionnant donc je vais
commencer par retirer la protection du
soda cut
voilà je viens mettre dans la poche
non aux mondiaux je connais pas son nom
je vais retirer
voilà pour découvrir la petite lame qui
se trouve à l'intérieur je vais prendre
une bouteille dont je tairai la marque
parce qu'il n'a pas
et je vais d'un geste tout à fait
experts retirer le fond de la bouteille
ça fait un petit peu de bruit c'est
normal la bouteille n'aime pas qu'on lui
c'est un traitement toujours pas non je
garde
ensuite je vais mettre à cali fonctions
le soda cut sur le bord de la bouteille
voilà et je vais d'un geste front et
vigoureux sortir quelques centimètres de
plastique
voilà et je vais pouvoir tirer sur ce
morceau de plastique pour en faire un
film
tout simplement comme une bobine je veux
aller jusqu'au bout parce que c'est sûr
pas grand chose voilà facile et alors
évidemment c'est bien beau cd super truc
mais vous avez bien à quoi ça sert cette
espèce de filaments de tagliatelles
plastique
oui effectivement alors moi j'ai déjà
trouvé ce que j'en fais j'en fais des
lacets pour mes chaussures déjà
totalement étanche idéal pour faire de
la moto oui depuis tout ça évidemment
aux fab lab on parle de faire de la
vannerie on parle de faire des sacs à
main des chapeaux tout un tas de choses
ce sont des bonnes idées maintenant
c'est vrai que ce qui nous intéresserait
vraiment aux fab lab c'est de pouvoir
prendre ce fils tel qui est là et de
l'introduire dans nos imprimantes 3d
pour créer de nouveaux objets ou
peut-être créer d'autres sautent accueil
à partir de l'imprimante 3d et et cet
objet imprimé avec des déchets on va
s'en servir pour retraités d'autres
objets qui vont aussi servir à faire
d'autres sauna cut et on se retrouve
dans une espèce de pyramide qui permet
de faire circuler
le travail des déchets au niveau des fab
lab voilà
[Applaudissements]
moi je fais partie aussi du fab lab et
dans le cadre des choses qu'on fait
parce que je trouve qu'il ya pas de
meilleur exemple en fait de vous montrer
ce qu'on fait dans un fab lab parce que
on parler pendant des heures en réalité
concrètement c'est les réalisations qui
font les fab lab
après les membres évidemment et les
membres ils font des choses ils font des
choses extraordinaires
moi je voulais vous parler de ce truc ça
ça c'est à mon sens révolutionnaire ça
s'appelle une est liée aux hyènes c'est
une éolienne solaire alors tout de suite
vous me dis toi mais faire tourner une
éolienne non non c'est pas une bonne
idée et pourtant en fait il ya beaucoup
d'application grâce à ce petit support
qui permet de suivre la course du soleil
on a des panneaux solaires qui sont
dedans et ses panneaux solaires ils vont
induire une rotation alors pourquoi
faire tourner les panneaux solaires
mais si en fait il ya une très bonne
raison à ça il y en a même plusieurs
la première raison c'est que dans un
système classique de photovoltaïque vous
avez besoin de batterie ces batteries et
vont nous permettre de supporter la
montée en charge des appareils quand
vous branchez sur le système avec les
lions viennent vous avez pas besoin de
tout ça en fait vous avez une rotation
qui est induite par l'exposition au
soleil et cette rotation vous pouvez
tout de suite l'exploiter pour et la
récupérer pour alimenter une petite
pompe qui toute la journée va vous
remontez de l'eau sur un système
il ya plein d'applications possibles
mais on parle d'un système extrêmement
simple
c'est purement mécanique ça c'est la
première option la deuxième qui a porté
le l'objet c'est que en fait il ya un
problème avec des panneaux
photovoltaïques dès que vous monter en
température
vous perdez en rendement c'est pas
énorme mais c'est quand même important
ça fait à peu près 0 4% tous les degrés
à partir de 25 degrés donc un panneau
fixe quand il prend le soleil hyper de
la capacité hyper du rendement quand les
panneaux tourner dans notre petit
appareil qui est là il se refroidissent
exactement il se ventile
et donc ça permet d'envisager d'utiliser
des panneaux de troisième génération qui
sont très sensibles à la chaleur
c'est dommage parce qu'ils ont un
excellent rendement il coûte pas cher à
fabriquer avec ce système on va pouvoir
envisager de les utiliser pour un usage
de ce type est le 3ème mois c'est la
partie que je préfère qui est
extraordinaire c'est à force de tourner
autour avec les autres membres on a on a
beaucoup tourné autour de ce projet et
au bout d'un moment il ya une idée qui
s'est fait naître c'est qu'on a en fait
six panneaux qui sont connectés dedans
ils sont connectés par groupes de trois
et dans une installation solaire
classique vous avez malheureusement du
continu qui sort de votre panneau de
continue c'est pas très utile c'est si
pour recharger un téléphone mais sinon
les usages sont assez limitées alors que
là avec cette rotation si vous le faites
tourner à la bonne vitesse et que vous
avez évidemment un dimensionnement qui
est suffisant ben vous obtenez de
l'énergie alternative que vous pouvez
directement récupérés sans passer par un
onduleur sans passer par des batteries
donc c'est une exploitation directe de
la capacité solaire
ça c'est tout nouveau ça a même fait
l'objet d'un brevet parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que personne n'y avait
pensé avant nous et dans un fable c'est
ça la bonne idée c'est que on vient avec
une idée au départ et puis grâce aux
fous furieux qui sont autour de nous on
va pouvoir l'exploiter
on va pouvoir faire des prototypes tout
ça c'est des prototypes qui sont faits
avec des matériaux de récupération ce
qu'on n'aime pas acheter du matériel
d'abord on n'a pas une thune pour
commencer et puis on récupère et on fait
des trucs avec alors c'est très design
c'est très joli c'est mieux qu'un nain
de jardin dans le jardin c'est superbe
et en plus bas ya de très bonnes idées
derrière et tout ça en creusant c'est ça
un fab lab c'est que on part avec une
idée qui semble un petit peu délirante
et qui finalement débouche sur de très
très bonne idée
et puis ce que je voudrais vous dire
c'est que vous pouvez venir aux fab lab
tout le monde peut venir au fab lab il
n'y a pas de mauvaise idée il n'y a pas
on n'a pas besoin d'être un barbu on n'a
pas besoin d'être un technicien vous
juste une idée venez venez y ai pas peur
venez vous confronter à ces gens là
quand un petit peu de technique dans les
mains ils vont vous aider
ils vont vous aider à faire avancer
justement votre truc qui vous parle est
délirant ou alors ils vont vous dire non
arrête arrête tout de suite mais sur un
malentendu comme ça on peut
éventuellement je sais pas à changer le
monde
vous aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à